- Who in your family
are you looking forward
to seeing on like, around Thanksgiving?
- It's football season.
- [Lauren] Ah,
I love Thanksgiving. I host it frequently.
I don't know if, if I'm
doing that this year
but I have a little niece
who's two years old who-
- [Kelly] Oh, fun.
- is just so much fun and
it's, everything's so new.
It's really fun to
introduce her to little-
- Magical.
- [Lauren] family traditions.
It's unbelievable. I mean,
- Yeah.
- she's just two in
Halloween so, yeah.
Excited to party with her.
- Yeah. Oh, that's such a magical age.
It's a fun time.
- She sings a lot-
- Everything you do is-
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- She's, she wants everything
the grownups have.
Unfortunately we've taught her
the word "margarita"-
- (laughing)
- every drink, every time
anybody has something,
she's like, "Margarita-ta-ta-ta,"
- [Kelly] (laughing)
- and so, she's gonna be-
- That's how you sound
after drinking several.
- Exactly.
- "Ta-ta-ta-ta."
(both laughing)
Not me. I've just heard about it.